[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute messbar
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem montag an
meiner seite ist für den sport norbert
könig hallo und wir haben unter anderem
diese themen für sie
werben für rot grün rot die linkspartei
umgang mit einem sofortprogramm spd und
grüne
einheitliche quarantäne regel für
schulen bundesweit soll nur noch
sitznachbarn für fünf tage zu hause
bleiben
und abschied von einem großen
schauspieler jean-paul belmondo ist im
alter von 88 jahren gestorben
der wahlkampf nimmt weiter an fahrt auf
die linke wittert die chance zum
mitregieren und war beute für eine
koalition mit spd und grünen
csu-chef söder dagegen warnt ein solches
bündnis stünde für höhere steuern und
enteignungen und spd-kanzlerkandidat
scholz der schließt ein bündnis mit der
linken zwar nicht explizit aus zeigt
aber keinerlei interesse andrea maurer
über mögliche regierungspartner
so sehen gut gelaunter spitzenkandidaten
einer partei aus die in aktuellen
umfragen bei gerade mal sechs bis sieben
prozent liegt die debatte über rot grün
rot eröffnet der linken eine neue
wahlkampfbühne selbstbewusst stellen
wissler und bat ihr sofortprogramm für
einen regierungswechsel vor es müssen
jetzt alle farbe bekennen weil wenn man
sein eigenes programm und seine eigene
kampagne ernst dann müssten eigentlich
spd und grüne relativ deutlich machen
dass das mit fdp und union eben nicht
umzusetzen ist die parteichefin meint
höheren mindestlohn kindergrundsicherung
klimaschutz mieten stoppt das bekenntnis
zur nato allerdings verweigern bislang
und butch und ziehen rote
außenpolitische linie also eine
regierung die die rüstungsausgaben
steigert und waffen in krisengebiete
liefert ehrlich gesagt die jetzt mit der
linken nicht geben
im kontrast dazu heute das treffen des
spd-kanzlerkandidaten mit dem
französischen präsidenten makro in paris
es geht um gemeinsame
verteidigungssysteme eine starke
kooperation in der nato beides
voraussetzung für jede regierungsbildung
sagt scholz als er nach einem bündnis
mit der linken gefragt wird und das kann
nicht allen versichern weil jetzt sein
kreuz bei der spd macht damit er mich
als kanzler bekommt wird auch den
kanzler kriegen den er sich vorstellt
nämlich einen der auf diese prinzipien
achtet die für die sicherheit
deutschlands von bedeutung sei ein
klares nein zu rot grün rot dass der
politische gegner von scholz fordert ist
das nicht beim politischen frühschoppen
in abensberg versucht der csu-chef
konservative wähler zu mobilisieren
und im kern geht es um eine einzige
frage wollen wir weiter ein bürgerliches
land sein oder wollen wir nach links
rutschen es sind noch 20 tage bis zur
wahl der wahlkampf wird immer mehr zum
lagerwahlkampf
die union drängt darauf dass olaf scholz
farbe bekennt und eine koalition mit der
linken ausschließt theo koll in berlin
warum macht er das nicht also formale
ist olaf scholz an einen spd
parteitagsbeschluss aus dem jahr 2013
gebunden wird wurde festgelegt dass auch
bündnisse mit der linkspartei nicht
grundsätzlich ausgeschlossen werden
sollen und taktisch dürfte es darum
gehen die trumpfkarte linksbündnis nicht
frühzeitig aus der hand zu geben denn
bei möglicherweise sperrigen
koalitionsverhandlungen könnte das dann
die fdp vielleicht gefühliger machen
angesichts der anhaltenden und massiven
warnungen der union vor einem solchen
linksbündnis stellt sich aber natürlich
die frage wie teuer ist eine solche
trumpfkarte für olaf scholz und da zeigt
sich dann dass zwar einerseits die
anhänger von union und fdp sehr deutlich
gegen ein solches linksbündnis sind es
andererseits aber von allen denkbaren
koalitionen immerhin die
zweitbeliebteste ist das politische
preisschild ist also noch relativ
unleserlich die einschätzung von theo
koll vielen dank
vor der bundestagswahl gibt es immer
mehr cyber angriffe auf deutsche
politiker die bundesregierung geht davon
aus dass der russische militär
geheimdienst dahinter steckt deshalb
heute deutliche worte in richtung moskau
man fordere die russische regierung mit
allem nachdruck auf diese unzulässigen
cyber aktivitäten sofort einzustellen
sagte eine sprecherin des auswärtigen
amts
zum thema corona in den meisten
bundesländern läuft die schule wieder
heißt für zehntausende schülerinnen und
schüler aber auch ab in quarantäne stadt
ins klassenzimmer denn anders als bei
älteren gibt es bei den jüngeren wenige
impfungen und viele infektionen die
sieben tage incidence beträgt bei den 65
bis 84-jährigen aktuell 14 bei den 15
bis 29 jährigen ist 17 mal höher die
quarantäne regeln sind bisher aber je
nach region verschieden mal gelten sie
nur für infizierte mal für die ganze
klasse jetzt soll einheitlichkeit her
guido jahren am evangelischen gymnasium
in meiningen thüringen wollen sie kein
risiko eingehen zwei tests pro woche und
zwar alle also auch geimpfte und
genesene dazu maske und lüften damit
keine infektion in die klassenräume
geschleppt wird ich würde mir natürlich
wünschen dass wir
jetzt wirklich eine starke
einschränkungen durch kommen um einen
doktor man gewöhnt sich schnell an diese
regeln und sie sind ja auch jetzt nicht
ganz
absurd bisher schickte schulleiterin
schenker infizierte und die ganze klasse
in quarantäne nun bundesweit eine
vereinheitlichung nur noch die engsten
kontakte sollen nach hause geschickt
werden haben die gesundheitsminister
beschlossen dann haben wir auch
beschlossen dass man sich am fünften tag
mittels eines pcr tests bzw eines
antigens schnelltest aus dieser
quarantäne dann frei testen kann also
eine verkürzung dieser maßnahme denn bei
klassen quarantäne würden viele kinder
ohne infektion mit daheim bleiben
bestraft so der
bundesgesundheitsminister 14 tage ist
natürlich eine lange zeit insbesondere
wenn es um kita und schule geht was ja
auch dann für die eltern sehr sehr
herausfordernd ist nur infizierte und
sitznachbarn in quarantäne zu schicken
fand die schulleitung in meiningen
bisher nicht sicher genug für uns als
schule am umsetzbar ssten wäre es
natürlich auch die ganze klasse in
quarantäne stecken weil wir zum beispiel
auch nicht wissen wo die schüler sich in
der pause aufhalten sie werde die neuen
regeln umsetzen sagt die schulleiterin
ob das auch andere tun wird sich zeigen
es wäre nicht der erste flickenteppich
nach einer bundeseinheitlichen regelung
quarantäne für schülerinnen und schüler
wie gut sind die neuen regeln darüber
spricht zdf heute live um halb neun mit
dem virologe jonas schmidt-chanasit und
sie können mitdiskutieren auf facebook
youtube und in unserer app kommen wir zu
den aktuellen corona zahlen das robert
koch institut meldet vier
1749 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind 190 mehr als vor einer woche
die sieben tage incident steigt auf
84,3 innerhalb eines tages kamen 104
krone infizierte neu ins krankenhaus die
sieben tage incidents hier ist gesunken
auf
1,64
sie ist eine symbolfigur der
protestbewegung in belarus
maria kohl s nico war eigentlich
flötistin bei den massenprotesten in
minsk war die 39-jährige international
bekanntgeworden im gegensatz zu vielen
anderen oppositionellen blieb sie in
ihrer heimat wurde vor einem jahr
festgenommen und heute verurteilte zu
elf jahren haft christian senn berichtet
trotz handschellen formt maria kohl s
nikkor war kurz vor dem urteil wieder
ein herz dieser geste ist sie bekannt
geworden heute der schuldspruch gegen
sie und ihren mitangeklagten maxim's
nach trotz der repression und brutalität
gegen regierungsgegner versammelten sich
vor dem gerichtsgebäude in mainz einige
unterstützer
wir halten das urteil für widerrechtlich
und unbegründet es basiert nicht auf
beweisen im verlauf der gerichtlichen
untersuchung des falls sind weder ihre
schuld noch die verübung der verbrechen
bestätigt worden der rahmen sie
bezichtigt
der vorwurf verschwörung zur
machtergreifung sowie der aufruf zu
aktionen gegen die nationale sicherheit
kulissen die koffer waren letzten jahren
zu einer der prominenten anführerinnen
der massenproteste gegen diktator
lukaschenko geworden zusammen mit
präsidentschaftskandidaten svetlana tier
an oskar und veronika zepp carlo
kämpften drei frauen für ein freies
belarus ohne lukaschenko hunderttausende
im ganzen land gingen mit ihnen auf die
straße kritik am urteil heute auch von
menschenrechtlern wir sind empört über
dieses urteil auch wenn es nicht
überraschend kam wir haben gesehen dass
dieser fall von anfang an völlig
erfunden waren ganz offensichtlich aus
politischen gründen um maria kohl es in
die koffer maxim's nackt und millionen
von menschen die ihm folgten und an
friedlichen protesten teilgenommen haben
zum schweigen zu bringen
auch mehr als ein jahr nach den so
umstrittenen
präsidentschaftswahlen hält sich
diktator lukaschenko weiter brutal an
der macht coole sneakers und snacks
anwälte wollen in berufung gehen obwohl
sie ahnen dass das nichts ändern wird
nach afghanistan dort melden die taliban
die letzte bastion des widerstands
erobert zu haben dass pandschir tal
die provinz liegt rund 150 kilometer
nordöstlich von kabul in einem engen tal
am hindukusch und gilt als schwer
zugänglich
widerstandskämpfer verteidigten die
region in den 80er jahren erfolgreich
gegen sowjetische panzer und auch den
taliban gelang es danach nie pangäa
einzunehmen und auch heute gibt es
zweifel tom pollock berichtet
die flagge der taliban wird nun auch im
pandschir tal vor dem gebäude des
provinzgouverneurs
zumindest sollen diese bilder dies
belegen und ein beweis sein für den
taliban sieg gegen die
widerstandskämpfer der region ein
taliban sprecher sagte dazu später wenn
jemand zu den waffen greift sich als
widerstand bezeichnet und unruhen
anzettelt ist er zweifellos der feind
des ganzen landes und unseres volkes
denn das volk will nicht dass der krieg
fortgesetzt wird doch der gegner die
nationale widerstandsfront im pandschir
tal bestreitet den sieg es werde weiter
geht angeführt wird das bündnis
verschiedener oppositionsgruppen von
ahmed massud schon sein vater war ein
erbitterter taliban gegner in einer
audio botschaft fordert massud wo sie
auch sind ob innerhalb oder außerhalb
afghanistans ich rufe sie auf einen
nationalen aufstand für die würde die
freiheit und den ruhm unseres landes zu
starten
ungeachtet dessen lassen die taliban
keinen zweifel an ihrem sieg den
menschen im land versprechen sie auch
heute wieder freiheit und wohlstand
dabei weiß laut uno momentan jeder
dritte in afghanistan nicht wo er seine
mahlzeiten her bekommen soll einem un
abgesandten haben die taliban zugesagt
humanitäre helferinnen und helfer zu
unterstützen
auch um die versorgung mit hilfsgütern
sicherzustellen
es wird sich zeigen was von diesem
versprechen übrig bleibt aus angst vor
den neuen machthabern sind viele
familien aus dem pandschir tal in die
berge geflohen die botschaft der
widerstandsfront jedoch ist eindeutig
aufgeben gegen die taliban wollen sie
nicht
zurück nach deutschland auch heute
wieder mussten bahnreisende froh sein
wenn sie sich überhaupt noch in einen
zug quetschen konnten 70 prozent der
fernzüge fehlen aus wegen des streiks
der gewerkschaft deutscher lokführer
der ist zwar in wenigen stunden vorbei
aber der nächste könnte schon
bevorstehen denn zwischen bahn und
gewerkschaft bewegt sich nichts daniela
sonntag berichtet
viele warten auf wenige züge auch hier
am erfurter hauptbahnhof wieder ein
streiktag bei der deutschen bahn die
kunden zwischen genervt und
verständnisvoll ich finde es auf der
einen seite richtig das was getragen
wird aber am ende bestrafen die
passagiere waren frauen ich bin froh
dass das recht genutzt wird und ich
meine ganz ehrlich so ungerechtfertigt
ist es auch nicht die fahrgäste können
nichts dafür dass nicht genug lohn
gezahlt wird dann verstehe ich das nicht
warum man das auf die fahrgäste quasi
überwälzen muss der druck auf die gdl
wächst der vorwurf es ginge nicht um
tarife sondern um politik nach dem tarif
einheits gesetz geht immer nur der
vertrag der größten gewerkschaft die gdl
will deshalb auch für mitarbeiter zb in
werkstätten und verwaltung verhandeln
die bahn wurde dies nicht zulassen ich
muss mich nicht einigen auf 3,2 prozent
wenn die bahn uns dauerhaft beschränkt
auf lokführer zugbegleiter
bordgastronomie und damit verhindert
dass wir die mehrheit im jeweiligen
betrieb tatsächlich auch erreichen
können die deutsche bahn kündigt an dass
ab morgen wieder alles nach fahrplan
fahren soll und kritisiert den
arbeitskampf es ist unverantwortlich in
einer solchen phase zu streiken in der
in zwei bundesländern in sachsen und in
thüringen die ferien zu ende gehen und
in bayern und baden württemberg die
sommerferien ja noch anhalten heute kein
neues angebot der bahn keine
verhandlungsbereitschaft bei der gdl
eine annäherung im tarifstreit nicht in
sicht
die schönsten frauen der welt hingen an
seinen lippen frankreichs film ikone
jean paul belmondo ist gestorben mit 88
jahren
er verkörperte vieles den draufgänger
den frauenschwarm sowieso auch den
komödianten in rund 80 filmen spielte er
mit darunter die großen klassiker der
nouvelle vague eine würdigung von thomas
walde
jean paul belmondo will profi boxer
werden hat aber in dieser rolle wenig
erfolg er macht eine
schauspielausbildung bekommt auftritte
am pariser bühnen und dann empfehlen mit
romy schneider in ein engel auf erden
sind ein sehr netter junge
dank der durchbruch kommt 1960 außer
atem macht belmondo zum star der film
wird ein klassiker des internationalen
kinos belmondo spielt mit ursula andress
jeanne moreau und sophia loren hier im
film und dennoch leben sie ein merkmal
belmondos er macht seine stunts selber
am ende blickt er auf 80 filme zurück
es ist etwas besonderes am ersten tag
war es fantastisch und 40 jahre später
ist das immer
1999 erleidet belmondo einen
schwächeanfall auf der bühne zwei jahre
später einen schlaganfall er ist
halbseitig gelähmt und kämpft sich
mühsam ins leben zurück frankreich
würdigt heute einen künstler der den ruf
des landes in der welt mit geprägt hat
präsident micron lobt ihn in den
höchsten tönen
jean paul belmondo war ein nationaler
schatz voller elan und guter laune mit
scharfer zunge und geschmeidigen körper
ein erhabener hält und eine vertraute
gestalt ein unermüdlicher draufgänger
und zauberer der worte in ihm fanden wir
uns alle wieder
belmondo war mehrmals verheiratet hatte
vier kinder und sechs enkelkinder der
mann in dem sich die französische nation
wieder fand wurde 88 jahre alt
ach ja jetzt zu dir norbert die deutsche
fußballwelt ist gerade mal wieder in
ordnung oder ja es könnte das
startsignal 3 für einen aufbruch in
bessere zeiten
sechs zu null gewinnt die
nationalmannschaft gegen überforderte
armenier die tabellenführung übernommen
sollte auch übermorgen in reykjavik
gegen island ein sieg gelingen dann wäre
es eine perfekte neun punkte woche auf
dem weg zur wm 2022 nach einer
regenerationseinheit im hotel hatten die
meisten spieler heute frei so willi riß
an der gestern zu den besten zählte beim
kleinen fußballfest gegen einen
limitierten gegner so gut hatte man das
team schon lange nicht mehr spielen
sehen der auftritt weckte freude beim
neuen bundestrainer und bei den fans
18.000 zuschauer hier in stuttgart so
dann solch eine stimmung ist einfach ist
einfach genial und ich glaube jeder war
bereit alles zu geben
traumkombinationen hohes tempo eine
demonstration der spielstärke auch
doppeltorschütze sascha brie hat seine
treffsicherheit wiedergefunden
ich habe spaß gesehen freude gesehen und
im endeffekt ein gutes ergebnis es gab
zwei premieren jonas hofmann und der
erst 19 jährige debütant karima dmi
geschossen ihr erstes länderspieltor es
war eine aufbruchsstimmung zu spüren
doch der überzeugende auftritt kann nur
ein anfang gewesen sein
brasilien gegen argentinien das war
gestern der kürzeste südamerika
klassiker der fußballgeschichte die
staatsmacht beendet das
wm-qualifikationsspiel wegen verstößen
gegen korona bestimmungen
fünf minuten gespielt als beamte der
brasilianischen gesundheitsbehörde und
der bundespolizei das spielfeld betreten
rudelbildung hitzige diskussionen dabei
auch die superstars neymar und messi 4
argentinische profis alle noch am
letzten wochenende beteiligt in der
englischen premier league haben dies
nicht angegeben wollen damit eine
drohende zweiwöchige quarantäne umgehen
unklar warum drei von ihnen ist trotzdem
bis auf den rasen und in die startelf
geschafft haben das ist zwar das gesetz
aber alles ist doch sehr verlogen die
behörden toulouse songs auch nichts man
hätte das problem auch anders lösen
können die korona pandemie sorgt für
chaos und der weltverband fifa muss
jetzt entscheiden ob und falls ja wann
das spiel nachgeholt wird
der siegeszug von peter gojowczyk bei
den us open ist gestoppt der qualifikant
unterlag im achtelfinale dem erst 18
jährigen spanier carlos alcaraz und
angelique kerber verliert ebenfalls in
einem duell der generationen
die 18 jährige leila fernandes im
vordergrund die schon titelverteidigerin
nach osaka bezwungen hatte beendet
vorzeitig körpers traum vom vierten
grand slam erfolg mit 4 6 7 6 und 6 2
setzt sich die kanadierinnen gegen die
33-jährige deutsche durch
auch noch mal 33
träume nicht das wetter beschert uns
weiterhin einen schönen und zum teil
auch richtig warmen spätsommer details
dazu hat gleich aus dem verlies
christian sievers freut sich auf sie im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn wir
sind morgen wieder da danken für ihr
interesse und wünschen ihnen einen
schönen abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
juncker mahnte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter ja das warme spätsommerwetter
geht in die verlängerung
das hoch über mitteleuropa hat sich
ausgedehnt weit in den osten europas
aber sehen hier kommt feuchte luft mit
wolken vor allem im norden deutschlands
ansonsten gibt es einen tief ganz im
westen europas und das wird in der
zweiten wochenhälfte dann für schauer
und gewitter sorgen schauen wir auf die
kommende nachts da gibt es vor allem im
norden mehr wolken als im südwesten
örtlich bildet sich nebel und die
temperaturen sinken auf 8 grad am
alpenrand und 14 bis 15 grad nach
südwesten hin die morgen im tagesverlauf
löst sich der nebel allmählich auf und
die sonne kommt hervor die tendenz im
norden zu merken ist gegeben im
südwesten ist es freundlicher nach
südosten hin dann in den
nachmittagsstunden schauer und gewitter
vereinzelt zumindest bei temperaturen
bis 29 grad am oberrhein und 20 grad an
der ostsee sie sehen ganz im westen und
im süden deutschlands ist es deutlich
wärmer als nach nordosten in die
kommenden tage bleiben erst einmal waren
mittwoch bis 28 grad trocken donnerstag
erste schauer und gewitter durch aus dem
westen anzutreffen freitag können die
auch ziemlich kräftig ausfallen
temperaturen bis 27 grad und damit einen
schönen abend